every industry has performers that give
different levels of respect when they
walk into a room whatever that blue may
be let me give you an example so in
Hollywood when they do their Oscars or
their red carpet and the you know
Academy Awards and all the actors are
walking the red carpet
you know there's actors everybody but
everybody gets respect hold on gosh look
how pretty she is oh my gosh look at her
and some years and then there's a
certain level of respect with certain
actors and then there is respect when
the one person walks in right or even in
sports and be a all-star game like you
you know it all the players go to it the
players walk into the arena of Raisa
call okay oh look who's that oh and then
oh my gosh look he's here
the same goes in sales offices your
company everything see there are people
that want this kind of respect and they
want to do this kind of work but let me
give you an example here look in my
office perfect example you ready
watch this here I'll give you a perfect
example here when this guy walks in the
arena what's the reaction what is the
reaction when he walks in the arena so
imagine there's ten quarterbacks first
one Brett Farr walks in bars in here
Peyton Manning walks in oh my gosh to
pick Manning Aaron Rodgers walking oh my
gosh
Tom Brady walks in silence why that's to
the best no Andy Scott walks in Tigers
in the room when that guy walks in you
know when when when a lot of these guys
walk in any of these guys walk in
silence oh he sent a wrong did you sue
just walked into the room what's the
moral distort here's what it is the
number one reason why when Brady walks
in everybody stays quiet or Tiger or
Jordan walks in there was like oh my
gosh or a Daniel day-lewis walks and
Meryl Streep you know why and this is no
political message and I know Hollywood
and Academy has a lot of political stuff
going on right now here's what number of
reason most people slow down after
winning a success
it's the memo reason for people slowing
down
there are different types of reactions
people have when they went door those
who went they say oh my gosh I want to
experience this even more this was
incredible
how can I take this thing to a different
level so Daniel day-lewis last of the
mohicans you know whether it's Lincoln
it's one after another Brady
championship after championship I won't
do it again and again I'm coming back
you know I went two years 26 million I'm
gonna come back Michael Jordan back to
back to back back to back to back I want
to come back Tigra I understand my backs
I've done so much surgery I want to win
the Masters again they keep coming back
they keep coming back but the number one
reason as most people slow down so now
why do we have so much respect for these
guys that keep showing up see because to
them it wasn't about the money
never forget what Kobe said to me this
last week when I was sitting down with
them he says Patrick I knew the
difference between the NBA of reading
who was really in the game that was my
competition in high school it was very
easy to read the people in the NBA I
said well what was that he says some of
these guys got into the NBA just for the
contract the moment they got paid they
slowed down he said I wasn't in the
league for the money he's a guy in the
league because I wanted to compete I
wishes from 13 years old I knew I wanted
to be one of the greatest of all time
from 13 years old he didn't going for
the contract by the way all the other
guys that made the money they went in
for the money they're today broke and
they barely have any money to themselves
maybe 5 10 15 20 50 million dollars
Kobe's worth a half a million dollars
today and he's not gonna stop because
it's continuously growing here's a moral
distort the next time you have a big
victory whatever it may be had a guide
today an entrepreneur came in from
Chicago he's a hardcore value chain or
big-time by detainer from the moment he
started watching my team into today took
his business from zero to 20 million
dollars is what he did the last 12
months twenty million dollars 32 year
old kid the twenty million dollar grown
man just bought a 10,000 square-foot
house in one of the most exclusive parts
of Chicago I'm not even gonna say his
name is Tim he's a Syrian absolute beast
but he came and we started talking in
the car I said the only thing I want you
to keep in mind is the following when
you win and you start making money and
everybody gives you the attention and
you get the house the cars the jewelry
don't get cocky
do not get cocky stay a little bit
paranoid keep getting better keep
improving because the level of respect
changes so imagine if you're in a
gathering and you walk into Russia oh my
gosh look what the person is in here and
then all of a sudden the real guy shows
up and it was a cool he just showed up
everybody stays quiet there's a big
difference two levels you just got to
ask yourself what kind of level of
respect you want do you just want the
level of respect to winning once do you
just want the kind of a level respective
you don't maybe a couple times or do you
want the kind of level of respect like
those guys are getting on that wall
because those guys didn't stop after
winning once or twice or three times
they kept going and going and going and
going until their peers said man I'm
done you can play until 42 if you want
I'm retiring buddy you know that is
yours are here and I'm gonna go and
chill out and do my things I don't even
know why you want to keep doing what
you're doing no problem because the
League of the greatest has only left for
one person not for two only one wants to
do that so for you how big of a business
do you want to build what kind of
respect you want to have the next time
you walk in to your meeting just another
person walk into the room
maybe we're into top ten may go into top
five or the best in that group or the
best of the best of the best you know
it's the great thing about this question
here only one person gets into the
question and it's you but if you said
yes you want that kind of respect let me
tell you all the partying the
distractions all the other things that
everybody else is doing you got to pay
more and more and more and more close
attention to details because that's what
it's gonna take to get to the top and
stay up there for year after year after
year after year after year it's a league
only for a small group of people this is
why not a lot of people watch videos
like this one because it's draining to
most people most people want to go watch
some cat videos or some lizard videos or
dinosaur videos they don't want to watch
a video like this about working hard to
be the best of the best of the best but
the few of you that you're still
watching and you're crazy you're my kind
of people can't wait to see you go kill
it out there anyways have a great week
everybody take care bye bye